the first three nonzero terms of the
Maclaurin series for the function f of X
is equal to X cosine of X so one thing
that you're immediately going to find
well let's just remind ourselves what a
Maclaurin series looks like so our f of
X can be approximated by the polynomial
we're going to evaluate F at 0 that's
why it's a Maclaurin series it's going
to be centered at 0 it's a Taylor series
centered at 0 plus F prime of 0 times X
plus the second derivative evaluated 0
times x squared over 2 plus the third
derivative evaluated at 0 times X to the
third over 3 factorial we could view
this as 2 factorial as well and we keep
going on and on and on forever and what
you're immediately gonna find is when
you start taking the derivative of F and
in the second and the third and the
fourth and the fifth derivative your
next chap you actually gonna take a
bunch of derivatives here every time
we're gonna have to apply the product
rule this is going to get very hairy
very very fast so there's actually a
trick to this problem what we want to do
we could find the Maclaurin we can find
the three the first three nonzero terms
of the Maclaurin series for cosine of X
and then just multiply that by X because
you know if we just X cosine of X you
could use the same thing as x times the
or another way of saying it is the first
3 terms of the Maclaurin expansion for
this is just going to be x times the
first three terms of the Maclaurin
expansion for cosine of X so let's do
that
so to do that let's just think about the
various derivatives of cosine of X so if
f of X I'm use a different letter here
for the function if G of X is equal to
cosine of X then G of 0 is going to be
equal to 1 and then the first derivative
would be equal to negative sine of X so
the first derivative evaluated at 0 is 0
sine of anything or negative sine of any
of 0 I should say it's going to be 0 and
then the second derivative
well derivative of sine is cosine so
it's negative sine so it's negative
cosine of X and so we're gonna have so
the second derivative evaluated at 0
is going to be equal to negative one you
might start seeing a pattern here the
third derivative of X is equal to is
equal to sine of X and so if I evaluate
the third derivative at 0 I'm going to
get 0 again and then when I take the
derivative of this when I take the
fourth derivative I get back to cosine
of X the fourth derivative is the same
thing as the function so the fourth
derivative evaluated 0 this is also
going to be the fourth derivative I'll
write it like that
evaluate it at 0 this is also going to
be the fifth derivative evaluated at 0
the cycles this is going to be the sixth
derivative evaluated at 0 this is going
to be the seventh derivative evaluated
at 0 and so what are the first what are
the first three nonzero terms let's see
it's going to be this one it's going to
be this one and it is going to be this
one and so we have we're gonna have this
term we are going to or let me just do
it for cosine of X so let me write this
down so I'm gonna write and you might
already know then what the first three
nonzero terms of the Maclaurin series
for cosine of X but I'm finding it here
for us so cosine of X is approximately
equal to the first term here is just
cosine of 0 so that's just 1 and then
the next one is going to be our second
derivative so it's minus 1 over 2
factorial times x squared this is the
one that involves the second derivative
x squared and then we're going to
involve the fourth derivative and the
coefficients 1 so it's going to be plus
1 over 4 factorial times X to the fourth
if it involves the fourth derivative
then what was it's gonna be divided
divided by 4 factorial it's gonna be
times X to the fourth and there you have
it these are the first three non zero
terms of the Maclaurin oh sorry this is
the first three terms of the non these
are the first three nonzero terms of the
Maclaurin series for cosine of X and so
then we can say X cosine of X so x times
cosine of X
I'm just gonna multiply each of these
things by X so I'm multiplying one way
the thing but I'm multiplying both sides
of this times X so I'm getting X minus 1
over 2 factorial times X to the 3rd
power plus 1 over 4 factorial times X to
the fifth power and we're done and even
though this might have seemed a little
hairy and a bit of a long process and
some people have it somewhat committed
to memory what the Maclaurin series
expansion of cosine of X and sine of X
are and sometimes e to the X as well and
then this could be a very fast process
where you just multiply that by X but as
you can see even finding that Maclaurin
series expansion for cosine of X isn't
too bad if you've done it the other way
if you just try to take the first second
third fourth fifth or all the way to the
fourth derivative of this and evaluated
zero it would have gotten very very very
hairy